bueno a estas horas está sonando muy
fuerte el nombre del general miguel
hidalgo quien ha sido el director
general de la policía también ha sido
ministro del interior en el gobierno en
el segundo gobierno del ex presidente
alan garcía pero lo que llama la
atención es que hay rumores que está de
destitución o mejor dicho a la
aceptación de la renuncia del ministro a
benin o bien ha causado también molestia
en algunos miembros del gabinete de
gobierno y que el presidente pedro casi
no tenía que afrontar otros cambios y
que se menciona que también la primer
ministra mientras vásquez no estaría de
acuerdo como ha sido maltratado avelino
bien en las siguientes horas pedro
castillo juramentará un nuevo ministro
del interior y sabremos entonces si es
que va a también realizar otros cambios
situación muy difícil para pedro
castillo